you look like the assistant coach on the
women's golf team at Rutgers that's what
I feel like that's not bad that's my bad
you look like the creepy high school
women's volleyball coach who [ __ ] all
the players and it gets busted hot it's
busted for it come on you look like a
high school lacrosse coach who [ __ ] the
players Oh what are the players boys or
girls girls doesn't matter it's it's all
illegal it's oh but I just want to know
from her peace of mind but you look good
man
not don't tell me that after the Hat why
not bro cuz that's like some of those
some of those lacrosse coaches are a
dime pieces and they're coaching the
women's team then they just start
[ __ ] a hot one man you look like the
guy that gets beat at the first round of
every video game bro is frustrating you
look like the kid he goes with our kid
but Stu broke so he watches everybody
[Laughter]
bro that move was sick uh yeah yeah back
up bro that was a thank you thank you
back the [ __ ] up bro my parents loved me
you have no quarters that was me bro and
when that dude was done I would go up
real quick and try to touch the controls
to see if it was still worth a little
hopefully these dad some lies left yes
it and then just push the little slots
in for the quarters man okay what tell
you what else you look like the dude who
goes to Dave & Buster's at Howard the
[ __ ] old you're still trying to jump and
crawl up to this [ __ ] skeeball pull
the balls out [ __ ] play track
yourself bro you look like Dave Boston I
could do the make shady carnival games
man the place is shady as [ __ ] one of my
friends went missing in there this guy
Jeremy that I used to go to high school
with makes sense I wouldn't trust it
ever now you look a little bit more like
bebop and rocksteady had a [ __ ] had a
third brother that try to do music can
you pull up the pocket minute and
Rocksteady please bro you look like you
look like Casey from the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles with Down syndrome and I
beat downs it like Casey bro yeah well I
beat Down syndrome I don't know who
Casey you know those Casey is from tears
a general store who's always trying to
[ __ ] April uh
drove the van had that bullshit-ass dude
you're Casey you look like Captain
Planet instead of saving the planet you
just [ __ ] suck [ __ ] bring up Captain
Planet for me you look identical if
you're a superhero
you're Captain Planet to the mat nah
he's the weakest a superhero bro he was
a captain of a whole planet that's you
look at the clavicles it does I ate my I
could do more traps work and he
definitely has that body I will have
that body soon dude you're on them roids
back on them Roy I'm not getting back
all over on the side of the highway star
injection bro do you don't know how you
get steroids anymore man
one guy I bought something awful one
that's tasty by the way you look like
Captain Planet the worst superheroes of
all time we that dumbass that's a
superhero that's Casey he fights crime
bro yeah he doesn't really fight it one
[ __ ] shot son wearing kid at a time
he just looks like you gotta steal stuff
from Hot Topic it looks like you
protects hot top feel like stealing from
that store you know what's crazy as my
sister can't even read but what does it
have to do with us right now
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one